[Music]
they are looking for the girl is your
child
[Music]
why are we going to Berlin to be
invisible it wasn't that I had not known
I was different there favors for you
wherever you go
they will protect you as I reach 16 I
realized Hitler had a plan for us we
have a new girl joining us today honey
his Vina League is a good German name
but your face so untrim she is my
mother's name
[Music]
shouldn't you be going with them
[Music]
he's spying on me I wanted to know if
you're all right
if his father catches you with his boy
he'll kill him before he comes and kills
us are you making problems for yourself
aren't you afraid of what what mostly I
think about what it'd be like to fight
to stand up for Germany like my father
did hey fly swatters boy I refuse to let
you be arrested because of her
you want her to be special I want her to
be like everyone else
we are the best of everything for each
of us there is someone Polly it's you
they say there's no such thing as an
across the bottom is
they say i'ma turn
horns
this isn't what a soldier does that is
precisely what the soldier does whether
he wants to or not
laughter where we both belong
[Music]
you